foreign
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on what
happened I said see that [ __ ] see what
[ __ ] that intro yeah yeah it was good
yeah I did it last night yeah I liked it
so we're gonna do this is going to be a
upbeat show I'm saying that because we
don't feel upbeat well it's gonna be I
don't feel that beat oh why not I don't
know I feel all right just um I'm trying
to get the same as usual trying to get
wound up just because we're gonna go up
we're gonna go to the club tonight we're
gonna go to Madigan's
yeah David will be up there
a bunch of people be up there it's
Friday the 13th
it is so I'm just gonna try to try to
get down there at a decent hour get some
parking
so uh we don't know how long the show's
gonna run we'll probably end it
maybe around eight or eight something
more time probably huh yeah because I
mean I already did all this all I have
to do is change clothes so it'll run for
a couple hours yeah I already know what
I'm wearing so I'm not really all that
worried about it
all right all right yeah Dave said he's
going mannequins later yeah well like I
said it was kind of like a thing because
mementos tonight too but I don't know we
haven't been in mannequins in a while
yeah I have more fun at mannequins
actually you know to be honest they're
just
it's more random anything can happen
there
that's true yeah you kind of know what's
going to happen when you go when you go
to uh with the other place Zach says
Tom's never upbeat LOL
[Laughter]
refrigerator today the the freezer
but which is good I didn't realize it I
didn't realize that the freezer door had
the freezer door was broken you know a
little plastic door yeah yeah opening it
with all that damn
uh ice built up in there broke one of
the tabs off but it was being held in
there by Ice
oh so once I thought it out the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] but the little broken
piece was still in there so I fixed it
okay I'll re-glued it I didn't expensive
part but I didn't do it I don't ever go
yeah I don't ever go in that freezer so
[ __ ] it had iced up it was hard I turned
it down I think that's a sign of it
being on to to uh too high in it
probably yeah okay
Dave says the baby bats are dressing as
killers and victims I guess that's the
theme I knew there was probably a theme
because it was Friday the 13th so what
are they doing this so they're Dave Dave
so they're doing like a slasher thing
I guess yeah all right that's that's
kind of cool that's good
that's
cool
yeah so
well gosh
you already ran out of [ __ ] to talk
about you are you are in a bad mood well
I just didn't have anything to add to
that oh okay um it's you're the one
you're the one that called attention to
me I'm just sitting here just trying to
get through the show uh we're gonna um
we saw a program last night Jenny wanted
to talk about it the damn
[ __ ] roommates from Hell worst
roommate ever yeah I just kind of like
started watching it randomly on Netflix
because I couldn't really think of
anything else to watch and I was like oh
this sounds intriguing and uh yeah it
was really something it was like a mini
series I guess because there was kind of
like I think what it was I think it was
like three or four episodes and then
like the last ones were like a
two-parter and when I went and did
research about it
I learned that the two-parter episode
like the last finale one the guy that
was about that was kind of where they
got the idea for the whole series and
then they did the other ones like later
you know what I mean so each one I don't
know I kind of feel like I was reading
this article about that guy about uh his
name's Jamison Bachmann I guess
and that dude is pissing me off I was
reading an article about him later and
basically like this article was like you
know they could have made the whole
series just about that guy because they
left a lot of stuff out like a lot of
other victims he had and stuff which you
know what I mean it's uh it could be
that
um you know some of the other people
didn't want to talk about it just so
funny because his childhood friend was
still standing up for him
kind of yeah I mean I guess he was just
kind of saying it's like well he was a
complicated person I'm like yeah well
everyone's a complicated person yeah
Jeffrey Dahmer was complicated as [ __ ]
too
but the you know you being a complicated
person that doesn't really like give you
license to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
you know once a [ __ ] got into
your house there was no getting rid of
him and you were gonna pay his way it
was the ultimate parasite
yeah this dude man what the [ __ ] yeah
like killed his own brother he did
eventually killed his own brother
because his brother wouldn't [ __ ] let
him move in
yeah and so they had like um a whole
bunch of people on there that it had
he's one of those dudes he I he went to
law school and he was apparently like
really really intelligent like and he
knew everything there was to know about
uh you know rental law and stuff like
that
and so but he never passed the bar like
he tried it one time and failed which is
you know a lot of lawyers do the first
time but then you just keep trying but
it's like he just didn't bother keep
trying he was an underachiever yeah I
kind of feel like he was just kind of
like oh well he's just gonna use all his
knowledge to move into people's houses
as a roommate and be like really cool
for like a couple of months and then go
oh by the way guess what I'm not paying
any rent and also I'm not leaving and
you can't make me leave because my mail
comes here and goes you know because
some states have laws where you can't
like if somebody's getting like moved in
and they get their mail there like it's
you have to like go through legal
channels to evict them
which you know
which is probably good because you can't
just like throw people out on the street
but you know what I mean it's just it
can be abused yeah uh by people like
this dude yeah because holy don't live
in this don't live in one of those
States if you live in one of those
states don't ever let anybody into your
[ __ ] you know I think [ __ ] Boston was
kind of like that Massachusetts uh I
don't think it was as bad as in other
places like in New York but
hell no
if I can um you want to live in a state
where you can let somebody move in but
you could but because you're on the
lease or that you're you're you the
title is yours to the place you kick
them right out that's what you want
because it avoid situations like this
you know
you can [ __ ] nobody has a right to
steal your property that's what they're
doing stealing your property well I mean
like I said a lot of these were rental
situations so the people didn't really
own the place now the one woman did like
she owned the condo but most of the
places were renting uh so the landlords
the landlord's issue I guess but that
dude wasn't renting no I know no I know
but I'm just saying that the people that
were living there that were looking for
a roommate were renting thank you very
much Aaron uh hanging out tonight with
you all while I'm at the gym having a
good Friday oh well thank you very much
thank you very much
yeah but uh but yeah so this guy
um wow what a [ __ ] psychopath and
like I said there was just like there
was a lot of stuff
my favorite girl that they talked to was
this girl whose name was um Alex or
Alexandra
and she had this nice apartment in uh it
was in Philadelphia I think
and she was looking for a roommate and
she found this guy like usually uh they
would find this now he was going under
an assumed name at this point like he
did use his real name for a long time
but he was going under in a soup name I
think it was Jed Creek or something like
that and
um she said like for the first two or
three months he was totally totally
normal and it's like they were even like
hanging out like friends and stuff like
that like he seemed totally fine and
then just all of a sudden he starts
getting like
um not leaving or you know what I mean
and not paying for anything and he would
just get more and more like sociopathic
like as time went on and it was just
like really I mean the [ __ ] that he did
and said was just
[ __ ] crazy it doesn't surprise me at
all that he ended up
well he did he tried to kill Alex I
don't know if he tried well he did
attack her like he grabbed her neck and
like was gonna strangle and then he cut
up her leg like with a knife yeah
um you know so he did do that but it's
like he did end up like killing his
brother like later on and his brother
had bailed him out of jail twice yeah
twice yeah like because he got arrested
at some point for all his Shenanigans
and his brother was nice enough to come
and bail him out of jail and then like
second time after he bailed him out of
jail he [ __ ] murdered the guy yeah
it's funny because you know they can't
get rid of the dude and he's making
everybody's [ __ ] life miserable
basically stealing and uh going into
other people's rooms and [ __ ]
harassing them and they're they try to
get rid of the dude through the law and
there's no way to get rid of him through
the law and I'm like dude you realize he
doesn't really have a family if he
turned up missing really it would be
it would be years before anybody [ __ ]
like he had a brother but it had been
years before his brother noticed that he
was missing they'd never be able to
isolate a time of death or anything like
that [ __ ] yeah I mean I kind of feel
like if you would say he's gone through
some channels and like uh you know
nothing was working out I was like I I
kind of feel like let's just make this
dude disappear how about that that's
what the mob was for if you had problems
that couldn't be solved legally you
hired the mob they would have folded
that [ __ ] up they would have folded
him up quick but the thing is is that he
was taking advantage of real poor people
who couldn't hire professional help to
fold his ass up you know I mean well
yeah because his phone is new he knew
who to take advantage who to take
advantage of it's like they you know he
was going after you know women that
lived alone or something like that they
were just kind of like oh they need help
with the mortgage so they need a
roommate he's going after poor people
basically yeah so then it's like when
you got in a situation it's like what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do you can't yeah
afford to like hire lawyers to to evict
him and all this other kind of [ __ ] he
was a tall dude which you know
intimidates a lot of people but there
wasn't nothing to him not physically you
know thank you Trey happy Friday guys
thank you you never did a hard day at
work in his life he fold him up pretty
easily but you know it was women he was
picking after women and he got had a gun
he had a pistol but that doesn't mean
anything to be honest if it was me I
think I probably would just poison his
ass
well he lives in the house with you you
just like you got to be nice to like
pretend you're nice to him and [ __ ] like
that and then just put some [ __ ]
arsenic or some [ __ ] in his life there's
much better ways but I'm not gonna make
well now two videos well now I'm just
saying that it's like if you don't want
all the confrontation and he's you know
he's bigger than me and [ __ ] like that
and you know he he lives there either
that or you could like [ __ ] kill him
while he's sleeping I would have wanted
the confrontation personally well yeah
but you know if you're a smaller woman
like you know obviously he's gonna like
[ __ ] you up because he's bigger but I'd
have kept him around and talked to him
for a few days
I did like that the Alex girl she was so
weird I loved her I don't know what it
was she was she was quirky I liked her
but uh this was in 2017 that this
happened because this was fairly recent
and I liked the way that she kind of
went about trying to get rid of him
because after she found out that like
she didn't really have a lot of recourse
she was kind of like okay well what are
all the things that he hates
um you know he doesn't like noise he
doesn't like Hip-Hops he doesn't like
smoking so she invited like 30 of her
friends over and they were all just like
smoking a blowing smoke under his door
and like playing really really loud
music and yeah he walked out [ __ ] in
a fit to go walk the dog so they took
the [ __ ] doorknob off so he couldn't
and I was just like why didn't they take
the door off I would have taken the
whole [ __ ] door off and they printed
out like a bunch because by this time
she had found out who he was because he
like I said he was under a fake name at
this point and she had found out like
well actually his mom like found like
her mom found out who he was and so she
had printed out like all of these
articles that she found about all of his
Shenanigans because he'd been doing this
for years and years like in different
cities and she like plastered him like
all over and she got like all her
friends to like make fun of him when he
came out of the room and all this other
thing yeah he was a Serial [ __ ] oh
yeah
it's just unbelievable and dangerous he
was dangerous yeah yeah he was very
violent also you know picking on poor
women basically is what you're doing but
um and he thought he was entitled and
[ __ ]
but it's good it's a good episode
there's two episodes that's double yeah
it's two like two months since the
finale yeah and there's a lot of some of
his victims were in there but he was
just like
really you know they were talking about
how intelligent he was I wasn't buying
it all right
he was he was intelligent in the way
that uh
oh [ __ ] what's his name was who's
that [ __ ]
that old serial killer Ted Bundy Ted
Bundy he was it was a severed head
[ __ ] yeah seven seven head [ __ ]
he was uh a Ted Bundy type yeah yeah he
definitely was he definitely was where
he was uh thought real highly of himself
uh he did have some intelligence but he
would be an underachiever couldn't
handle rejection uh if he failed once he
just gave up because he was too good to
fail what kind of deal he's one of those
guys yeah and then blamed everybody else
and he was kind of imploding when all
this is going on yeah and he knew that
nobody liked him so he just started to
[ __ ] maximize that against everybody
and blamed everybody else for him being
being a loser really just [ __ ] loser
um
just a douche man but he could he could
talk to women he could talk to women and
charm them but not for long just enough
to get into that and get into the
apartment once he was in the apartment
yeah click over to another mode because
a couple of the women that like I said
that they said that he lived there for
like the first couple months we're
totally fine they said he was totally
normal he was Charming like they would
hang out one girl one woman would start
to sleep with him yeah and like they had
a relationship that was in New York City
I think right now like three or four
years
yeah it took her like four years to get
it did she get kept trying to tell him
you can't live here anymore and he's
like [ __ ] you you know basically have
him do what I want you know yeah he
wouldn't pay for anything yeah nothing
made her pay for everything so the women
had to [ __ ]
pick up second jobs to [ __ ] pay all
the
all all you know all the yields
utilities and all the bills so he's
basically pipping these women out
sitting up in there like a king yeah
that's what I was saying I was just had
he done that to me he knew better he'd
just go after women
he would not go after men yeah it
wouldn't be men I mean he did he did
that one landlord he pushed his ass over
a lot but that was an old man
so he could do that oh man
well [ __ ] had he done that [ __ ]
to me he'd just come up missing I
wouldn't even know what happened I mean
dudes like that yeah you know they
that's their whole thing they're gonna
go after they're not gonna go after
somebody that's gonna like that they can
do something to him yeah you know what I
mean
like I said I would probably like
pretend to be nice to his face and then
poison his ass
hey
[Laughter]
you know you got to do something it's
like No One's Gonna Miss the [ __ ] I'm
doing the world a favor okay you go to a
[ __ ] bar with a whole bunch of
[ __ ] tough necks in that [ __ ] and go
make a [ __ ] huge boyfriend in there
and tell him the whole story and they go
over there and [ __ ] fold him up real
quick they just cook him up like bacon
get you a gangster boyfriend
yeah like I said somebody needed to make
that [ __ ] yeah he said this
because he just like ruined so yeah and
you could show him you could show him
like oh his whole [ __ ] jacket in
other words this whole [ __ ] profile
of everybody these victimized go this is
the [ __ ] and they go okay yeah
there are guys at that [ __ ] bar hang
out with that would you love that oh
okay yeah yeah we'll get him and now
it'll be the that'd be the end of him
yeah
well and warlocks had run through that
[ __ ] like like I said I kind of
feel like a lot of people didn't really
know because he moved around a lot like
he would go from City to city and after
a while he started using a fake name
like he had a fake identity and so
um and like I said he seemed Charming at
first but a lot of those sociopathic
type [ __ ] are well as I said on
the show they really only focused on
three cases you know what I mean which
like I said maybe that was like the the
main people that they could get to um
Talk on the documentary but he did that
a bunch of times like there was a bunch
more
people and you know what's weird too
they kind of brought this up and they
didn't really go into it but one of the
things because they were talking to like
a couple childhood friends of his
and they were saying oh well he changed
a lot after I mean I think they said he
was kind of a douche like even from
childhood but
um they said he kind of changed after
like he was in college and he was in a
room like or in a dorm room or something
like eating dinner with his friend and
like some [ __ ] just like walked
in and killed his friend like in front
of his face and I was just kind of like
we did that no he didn't he didn't do it
no he did it no yeah I looked it up okay
um but yeah yeah he didn't do it because
I would say to like but I was like wait
what what I was like can we have more
details about that please who was it who
was it that did it the catch guy yeah
they caught the guy okay who was he um
he was some other student like he killed
the guy what was his name um Ken it
started with a G like get it's it was
like gazoon type but it wasn't that okay
it was something like was it like a
German last name so that was the victim
and the guy that did it was the guy who
I think you know it was this morning I
read about this but he worked on campus
and he was was mad at this dude for
eating in the library because he worked
in the library and he had yelled at him
for eating in the library and so I guess
the dude had eaten in the library again
and this guy was so mad about it that he
came to the [ __ ] into like the
house or it was a dining hall or
something like that and just [ __ ]
stabbed him what was Louisiana you know
yeah it's Louisiana it was Tulane right
yeah yeah it's Louisiana
that's how you do yeah
yeah
yeah seems like a little bit overblown
it's just a just a bit very high crime
rate go look at New Orleans [ __ ]
crime rate you know the [ __ ] the
ninth ward is at least before the storm
I don't know it's like after the storm
when Katrina hit before Katrina that was
that was a [ __ ] dead body production
center right there that's just that that
was mostly that area right there but
just what a weird thing to get mad real
violet real violent what a weird o weird
to get mad about
I mean look um what was his name uh
Marilyn Manson Marilyn Manson and the
dude from Nine Inch Nails we'd run into
it Trent rezner they they lived in uh
off of Esplanade in New Orleans and they
they didn't stay there long I don't
think
but uh in Marilyn Manson's book He said
if you go hang out
in New Orleans you're going to end up in
one of three places a bar a prison or
another for one of one of four places a
bar a prison hospital or a cemetery in
jail says he named them all off I think
it was five places right three places
four places like whatever
that's true you eventually you either
end up in a bar a prison a [ __ ]
Hospital
or [ __ ] the cemetery that's that's
that's foreign
yeah that's it's kind of the same thing
bad place
but yeah well like I said it just seems
like I don't know that just seems like a
weird thing to get bad about like eating
in the library
it's like yeah it's gross but you know
what I mean yeah but yeah so that's what
I was thinking it was really weird that
they didn't go more into that like I get
that they didn't really want to focus on
that because it's like maybe it looks
like we're condoning like because oh
look at this traumatic [ __ ] that he went
through and you know but they did bring
it up but then I was just kind of like
well wait a minute like you brought that
up and then we're not like gonna We're
Not Gonna unpack that because so I had
to look it up like later on I'm like
what the [ __ ] was that all about that
was that was the 80s I don't yeah well
it was when he was in college it must
have been 80s so 80s or 90s maybe yeah I
don't I don't really know how to me by
10 years so it would have been it would
have been oh he was 10 years ago yeah
okay it would have been 80s probably
and then he he finally got caught for
[ __ ] killing his brother yeah and
then he hanged himself in prison so he
was dead and like a lot of the victims
of his were like really mad because they
were like they wanted him to due time
they wanted him to suffer you know what
I mean they're like he took the easy way
out
dad like a [ __ ] they dug up all his
friends from [ __ ] school
high school college
they liked him they said he had a lot of
um
said he had a way with himself
and um
he sounded like a chode honestly yeah I
think so too but they said he
but then people like that because they
kind of looked up to him because he had
a lot of Charisma and he but that one
did said that he kept catching him in
lies that he would lie about sleeping
with that girl and sleeping with the
other girl he was lie about that and
he's just like [ __ ] you didn't know
yeah
he was a good looking guy big tall
Jewish guy looked kind of yeah well
that's what I mean he wasn't like you
know he was good on guy right it wasn't
it wasn't kind of like you wouldn't
believe it but just the fact that he was
like yeah I'm just such yeah to me to me
it kind of reminded me a little bit of
[ __ ] um Leonard Nimoy kind of kind of
hunkier looking than Leonard boy but
Leonard was [ __ ] yeah women like to
Leonard no more yeah because Leonard I'm
always hot as [ __ ] yeah so he was just
kind of like that but tall but the thing
is he was a dude I think that peaked
early uh
I think he probably peaked in college
and that was probably about it he
couldn't really handle the [ __ ] he
couldn't really couldn't handle the
normal life in a working world
try to take over everything well like
you said I kind of feel like he was one
of those guys that he wanted to start at
the top well yeah he seemed to have a
like an
he was just like overly into himself and
I kind of feel like people like that
that have a really high opinion of
themselves sometimes if they do
something like for example when he took
the bar and he failed it
um you know a lot most normal people
would be like well you know I'll get
them next time gang because most people
fail the bar the first time most people
do
so um but he was just like oh well
obviously there was some other thing
going on and he just like never bothered
because I can he he felt like he was too
good
to like have to take it again yeah
because he didn't hurt his ego yeah yeah
I kind of feel like that's he seemed
like one of those kind of [ __ ]
if it doesn't work that way man [ __ ]
it's a constant struggle for everybody
it's not easy for anybody unless you
were born with a silver spoon in your
mouth you know like the top 500 American
families yeah you can't fail because
you're [ __ ] just because you just
have somebody constantly behind you
bailing you out you don't even need to
have a job right and I don't mean to
shock you people but those people have
all these advantage of all these [ __ ]
fancy sounding titles and degrees they
pay for most of them some of them will
have [ __ ] degrees from Harvard but if
you actually look into the [ __ ]
record they really didn't do any of
those classes they just kind of they
were there they hung out every now and
then but they just paid for it
because you donate [ __ ] 10 million
dollars to the [ __ ] thing is they get
it well yeah that's the thing and most
of the faculty will be like well we
can't really fail this [ __ ]
because you know they just paid for this
big new gym or this new whatever yeah
and he's never shown up you know right
living in town maybe if he's gone all
the time and never shows up and they
never fail him they just they just pass
him with D's
you know but all that kind of shit's
kind of Forgotten and then he's got his
degree
they don't care because he's never going
to work in that field anyway
it doesn't need to work
so you know but yeah I mean unless you
have like a super wealthy family most
people struggle which people don't even
need Pilot's licenses
they can buy a helicopter and just fly
it around between all their [ __ ]
private airports and
they don't even need uh passports
which that that's quite shocking but
they're so rich and they're so famous
and well known they don't need passports
he does some [ __ ] they made a special
offer that like I said yeah if you have
like a [ __ ] ton of money you can
basically just do whatever the [ __ ] when
you're in oligarch you can do whatever
[ __ ] you want oh why Jeffrey Weinstein
and his girlfriend what was her name
[ __ ] Lane Maxwell Gila and Maxwell
evidently was like a very accomplished
helicopter pilot and she'd fly this
helicopter around she didn't have a
license
and and evidently he just kind of taught
herself how to do it
that's [ __ ] mind-blowing
probably just
I have a hard time believing that she
taught herself but that's what they said
well why would you have a hard time
believing that because there's a lot of
stuff that you got to know yeah but
um the thing about it like flying a
helicopter uh a lot of people can do
that
um and if other people can do that if
you want to enough you can teach
yourself okay maybe I'm looking at from
a military point of view yeah flying a
helicopter you really have to know how
to maintain a helicopter also everything
about the helicopter she wouldn't have
to because she would she has a whole
ground crew to take care of that she
only needs to learn how to know how to
fly it
and uh she probably not gonna fly in any
kind of really bad weather conditions
only in good weather conditions
um but no the helicopter is hard to fly
it's harder to fly helicopter than it is
a fixed-wing aircraft It's Tricky yeah I
can see that yeah
it's kind of like flying a pogo stick
they say
I'd like to get it yeah I could see that
too yeah but yeah that's they don't they
don't want to hover yeah you know but
maybe it's easier now maybe they have
computers that well yeah everything's
like you know a lot easier nowadays
but no one thing that my grandfather
always taught me like this is one thing
that he always said that I always
remember because he taught this to all
his kids and he taught us to all his
grandkids he always said if someone else
learned to do it so can you he always
said that he's like you know no one else
is better than you they're not if
somebody else could learn to do that
then you can learn today I can fly I can
fly a little Cessna flew around the one
with my dad so that's why I don't think
I can't believe he won and the thing
about it now nowadays well that's kind
of the important part isn't it I could
probably I could get us down to the
ground and crash it into where we would
survive I don't think I could actually
okay well I'm not just let just okay I'm
not sure probably we never have to fly
any place I'm not sure I could actually
land on the runway itself
keep [ __ ] the wings from you know but
see taking off in flag it that's the
easy part that's the easy part it's
landing
and I'm like Landing that's kind of the
whole thing that you need to know how to
do throttle prop pitch and then you have
your [ __ ] control services and the
instruments are [ __ ]
the way the instrument panels are set up
and those things they cover you there's
they cover the [ __ ] forward view a
lot of it you're just looking at
instruments you're kind of flying by
flying by instruments a lot of times
compass and [ __ ] altimeter
but landing it when you're coming in for
a landing you look at the little bitty
[ __ ] Airfield down there and it's a
DOT and you're going like how the hell
are we gonna land on you just point the
nose at it in front of it
and you just gotta it's against your
instincts to point down at it but you
just point down at it until you're
eventually there and then you start
leveling off and [ __ ] then trying to
push down you gotta have balls let's
watch my dad do it
you know [ __ ] it my dad didn't own it
the owner was in the [ __ ] was was was
was in the back I was up in the [ __ ]
co-pilot's position
[ __ ] it was a little sasna but we
could you could uh
you could get into the back so we just
kind of traded seats you know what I
mean
it was a trip
but uh I'm just saying Harry he could
land it my dad could land it well that's
good yeah he didn't have a license
either
he was he was studying for it that's
great he didn't have a license he had
like a student's like a student's permit
type deal right like a learner's
interview
so he wasn't up there just like totally
being no no break or anything no the guy
that owned the aircraft was a doctor and
then he was afraid to fly by himself
because he had a heart condition
he was kind of tutoring my dad
but I don't think he ever actually got
the license
but see the thing about nowadays is that
nowadays it's like super easy to learn
how to do anything yeah
you know what I mean yeah and well and
the thing is it's you know you could
always do it if you wanted to bad enough
yeah but nowadays really anything that
you really really want to do I mean [ __ ]
man just go on the [ __ ] internet and
like you can learn how to do that [ __ ]
if you really want to learn to do it I
guess I was about 17 when that happened
17 or 18. I could get us on the ground
and we'd be alive but I think the
airplane would be all [ __ ] up would I
still have legs and stuff yeah
yeah
oh my God yeah John Smith said I saw an
article the other day about over comfort
overconfidence in the U.S 50 of men in
the U.S think they could land a plane
I'm surprised it's not higher than that
actually
I'm surprised it's not higher than 50
percent
the thing about it but it would not be
in one piece I'm realistic well the
thing about well probably 100 of people
who I could land it but do you want to
live through the [ __ ] I could crash it
into the grounds that's like pretty easy
to do I think everybody could teeth I
have a feeling because
I do have some experience with fixed
Wing craft and did a lot of flight time
in the Army and helicopters
and a lot of motorcycle riding time I
have a [ __ ] I love motorcycles um
I have a feeling that I could probably
land uh one of those ultralight
aircrafts better than I probably could
uh like something like a Cessna because
you're outside so I have kind of a
you're hanging up underneath the bottom
of it and it's small
and it doesn't have a lot of power it's
not moving very fast
and it's more motorcycle-like you know
what I mean that's kind of like a
motorcycle type feeling I think I'd be
more comfortable with that
it's not you're not you're not inside a
massive or relatively massive aircraft
but I've uh they've done like loads and
loads of studies and generally generally
not you know obviously you know it's
individuals are different but generally
men tend to be over confident and like
you know over uh what's the word I'm
looking for
I don't know their abilities
overestimate overestimate that's what
I'm looking for overestimate their
abilities whereas women tend to
underestimate their abilities in general
not always but um that's usually the way
it goes
but
so yeah so that doesn't I'm honestly
surprised it wasn't higher but like I
said Landing a plane
is easy like if you just let go of the
controls it'll just drop out the sky no
you landed it didn't you
well obviously I'm just saying that it's
like I I was surprised I would have
thought that it would be like 80 percent
of men said oh yeah I could totally land
the US Army even if they've never even
done it the US Army Air corps back in
World War II was taking tens of
thousands of [ __ ] dudes with no
flight experience of turning them into
pilots in a matter of weeks and then
setting them well yeah but they had
training though yeah the thing is though
is that they learned that quickly yeah
but I'm just saying that they're asking
just a bunch of random ass dudes can you
land a plane to people that have never
done it and they're like oh yeah totally
like obviously well they landed an
airplane for the first time on their own
but there was an instructor with them
right that's what I mean they actually
had structured training yeah
in doing if you kind of
if you had the feel for the aircraft and
understood the understood how what it
takes to land it you might be able to do
it on your own the first time
I kind of think but like I said hey
Pokey I saw you crawling around you're
probably gonna break the airplane up
though
that's what I think that's probably the
biggest danger I think you can get it on
the ground and you'd live but you'd [ __ ]
that airplane all up that's the that's
the most likely so is that considered
Landing it
I don't think that's considered Landing
it that's wrecking it
that's what I mean that's right yeah I
kind of feel like when they say oh
Landing it they mean obviously they mean
Landing it safe safely and then you can
take the area but I'm just saying
technically yeah everyone could land it
yeah you know what I mean because it'll
just fall out of the sky Tom Sykes says
the Barefoot Bandit learn how to fly a
plane via plane simulator and then
stolen aircraft and flew it away which I
remember being a badass kind of yeah and
well that's what I mean but to see a
simulator that's still training though
like you're still like interacting with
it like it was a real thing yeah I've
[ __ ] with simulators before so that
that means oh I could fly it no I could
I'd have to get the feel for it I know I
could take off like a taxi
I could get to the end of the [ __ ]
Runway and take off that's easy I could
fly it if you give me an Azimuth I can
[ __ ] shoot towards that Azimuth and
ride upon it uh [ __ ] if I had Maps
regular paper maps I could figure out
where I was going
could use [ __ ] terrain Association
and nowadays it's all electronic so it's
a lot easier than it was
it would but I'd have to go through all
of its navigational systems just in its
GPS to see how it's all that's it'd be
complicated it would be easier for me to
do it old-school way it probably would
be because now everything's more
technical whereas like that like I'd
probably be more comfortable with it
nowadays because I'm kind of more like a
technical yeah person but
I just want to look at a map and then
[ __ ] shoot an Azimuth across that map
of okay 270 mils for [ __ ] 400 miles
I'll be [ __ ] I'm going to be going us
you know [ __ ] 200 miles an hour so
I'll be there in about [ __ ] two hours
along this Azimuth when I get there this
is what the city looks like I'll try to
find that Airfield I'll I'll get down a
little bit lower and and just go by
terrain Association to find the Airfield
and then I'll [ __ ] point the nose
down the [ __ ] tip of the Airfield
then pull up once again slow everything
down you know [ __ ] Throttle Down and
[ __ ] just kind of coast in but you
got to have enough throttle that if you
have to [ __ ] abort the landing you
can come out but you're gonna try you I
would be good to know what landing speed
is you know it might be 90 miles an hour
90 knots or something you know
so you'd you'd have to get a feel for
how fast am I going
crafter says uh granther used to live
near the Albert desert in Oregon a
popular place for ultralights every year
someone would have to get squeegee off
the Playa oh yeah after a hard Landing
yeah Victor says I bet I could land a
plane if I was watching a YouTube video
on how to do it
well I mean that would be better than
nothing I kind of feel like like I hope
this situation never arises but if I was
in a plane like with one other person
and that person had a heart attack and
keeled over and I had to like and I was
gonna die if I didn't land it well yeah
I would obviously try to do it but I'm
not gonna say like oh I could totally
pull it off I would probably crash and
die probably I mean but I would try my
best
the big dangers are getting into stalls
and Spins well yeah and you had to know
how to get out of them you know [ __ ]
I know that if usually if you're in a
stall the best thing to do you lose
control you know control services is to
is to is to press forward on the
controls which is like down and then
pull back up and you'll try to get some
more airflow over your [ __ ] flaps so
you can regain control but there's
certain things like flat spins where man
you have to power your way out of it I
guess
[ __ ] put the throttle way up and then
just start to start [ __ ] hitting the
control services trying to get some
airflow over it but I don't know I
didn't never got that training but
there's just certain kinds of spins that
if you get you get into them you you
you're not gonna know how to get out of
them probably yeah
when an experienced pilot would
there's some [ __ ] that could happen to
be on a motorcycle that
I wouldn't know how to get out of it
there's been times where I've gotten
into slides power slides on my bike
and I got out of it and I don't even
know how I did it
just muscle memory and coordination you
know Body English it's just it happens
so fast I instinctively got out of it
somehow but I couldn't explain what I
did
well that's probably what happens and
that's just kind of because you've
ridden motorcycles for so long that it's
just become second nature yeah it's like
second nature so I kind of feel like
that's what happens after you fly planes
for a long time and [ __ ] like that you
just kind of instinctively know but it
takes a long time you know if you're
just completely inexperienced most
people aren't going to be able to do
that I was going through an intersection
and I was leaned over on the right and
[ __ ] went through the middle of the
intersection of the four-way
intersection and there was a pile of
sand there that usually builds up a lot
if they're not cleaning the roads and my
front end went through that pile of sand
and I lost my front end it started to
slide out from underneath me
and I got out of it I don't know how I
got out of the slide I know that I
throttled up I applied a bunch of power
uh which because that's what felt right
you're not thinking your body just does
it
so I sped up instead of slowed it down
you don't want to hit breaks you know
just but it happens so fast oh yeah
that's usually about it you can't think
it it just happened you know that I got
out of it and went whoa
it was over before it happened so fast
that that I didn't even get scared I got
scared after
because you thought oh that could have
gone that could have gone real bad yeah
yeah what the hell what how the hell did
I get out of that but like I said the
reason that you could do that was
because you've been riding motorcycles
for years and years and years and so you
have all of that muscle memory all of
that training and stuff like that when
you have all of that training under your
belt you have that you know it's just
Instinct yeah but like I said just a
random ass [ __ ] you know if I
was riding a motorcycle and that
happened I would have no idea what to do
and I would probably crash because I
just don't you know I don't have that
same training well I never had the train
that training it was just experience
well yeah but that's what I mean it's
kind of the same you're trying to run on
two pogo sticks two little one-inch
contact pads the rear tire the front I
mean but you probably had similar things
happen before like all right so right so
you knew what yeah what that was John
Smith said what kind of bike do you ride
Tom I got four all right uh the one that
I was sliding on was a Buell XB12R
yeah he has two you have two mules
I have two builts
I got an XB 12r that's been modified
into what what we call a lightning bolt
where it's part lightning and part
Firebolt
so it's kind of a hybrid bike I built
both bikes and the other built is xb9
lightning
it was the xb9sx lightning let's get
city cross
and uh it's modded out and uh
then I got
my dad's Honda CT70 trail bike I turned
it into a cafe racer
yeah I got it in another room over here
it's more of a decoration and you can't
go anywhere on it because you only have
one third of a gallon of gas and instead
of 70 CC's it's now 140 cc's so just
tricks fuel like crazy you can only go
about four or five miles for the gap for
the for the tanks empty and it doesn't
go that fast either no it goes 70. oh
does that oh yeah it goes 70.
the original only went about 25. yeah I
was kind of thing yeah but no now it
goes it doesn't have a speedo I had to
be clocked by a friend who was riding
next to me he says you're almost going
70.
uh but it only weighs for uh 50 pounds
the bike yeah me and him brought it up
the stairs yeah like when we moved it so
he could put it in it yeah
we just picked it up
it's um aluminum [ __ ] Wheels fat
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] Pirelli tires on it
uh inverted front end dual disc front uh
[ __ ] super bike bars it's got a
[ __ ] little Honda [ __ ] race tail
on it I shot a [ __ ] candy candy apple
green paint job with all I love the
paint colors yeah yeah I mean it's kind
of like the original it is the original
the original color the um
the uh I could easily win a a [ __ ]
show by competition with that in uh in
in [ __ ] pit bike or motor scooter
event you know because it's a small bike
very small and the other one I'm working
on is uh
it's a 1972 Yamaha rd350
it's just the rolling chassis and I have
the motor
um it's got an extended swing arm in the
rear off of a [ __ ] DZ
uh I was gonna take the motor and put a
400cc Banshee top end out of a [ __ ]
Banshee four-wheeler
and once it was all rigged up it was
only going to weigh
probably about 250 pounds and about 90
horsepower
maybe 200 maybe 200 pounds or 90. you
can pick that bike up I could easily
pick that bike up there's nothing too
it's a two-stroke
inverted front end dual disc front
uh uh gas shock dual shock rear uh the
the [ __ ] gas tank that I had on that
was a Yamaha gas tank off of uh of H1
is is it's it's wicked got Superbike
bars on it
it's just that uh I stopped working on
it I got the I got the
the motor and the Crag but I need new uh
jugs for it
uh I have to have the crank rebuilt
and uh
there's not too many people that can
work on Two Strokes anymore
so I'd have to [ __ ] do that crank
myself and put new bearings on it
it does it's a crank that comes apart
but you need special dies to press
everything together
so I kind of hit a dead end
if I could get my hands on a crank then
I can but the thing is is finding
finding [ __ ] parts for the
71 or 72 rg350 is hard now
you could probably get your hands on a
crank somehow
that sounded dirty and then I had to get
experience
some girl talk about a dick or something
but uh I gotta get here I gotta get
expansion Chambers for it the exhausts
are expansion Chambers on two stroke
that that level of [ __ ] two-stroke
you need expansion Chambers
didn't really make those anymore so you
had to find them all right
um
free for those of you don't know what
I'm talking about when it comes to Two
Strokes a chainsaw engine today would be
a two is a two-stroke engine
back in the 70s they had two-stroke
Technologies instead of a four-stroke
engine it gave you twice the power of a
four-stroke and and much less weight
but they kind of banned them for
emissions problems because you have to
mix
fuel in you had to mix oil into your
fuel that's how you lubricate your rings
this [ __ ]
so wherever you're going you're leaving
behind you a [ __ ] trail of [ __ ]
Blue Smoke
and it sounds like a [ __ ] swarm of
bees
[Music]
that's the way the thing sounds they
sound Wicked and [ __ ] leave smoke
behind
and I never had a two-stroke
so they sound like when they're when
they're idling
they're just Wicked little things just
love to live next door oh and make
everybody mad
grafter says Evil Knievel son Robbie
passed away today damn he had a few hard
Landings back in the day
yeah that's man that sucks
yeah he said I remember when he jumped
to Grand Canyon on a dirt bike yeah [ __ ]
great impression Tom yeah he's making
all the [ __ ] sound effects I can't
believe he didn't pick up on like the
the
getting hold of a crack joke
man I'm just I'm disappointed
uh wait what
Lisa Marie Presley died too
really like really or is that a hoax
because I know there's every time a
celebrity dies they're just like oh
never mind
ninety percent of the time they're just
like no that's just like a [ __ ]
you know that was just like a hoax but
she really how like she was that old
though right
I mean relatively I kind of feel like
she wasn't that old 54.
[ __ ] hell
[ __ ] hell
that is [ __ ] up yeah I didn't even
totally see that I was see that's the
thing I don't I don't I know I seem like
I'm really out of it and stuff but it's
just kind of like I don't hear about
stuff because it's just like I get up
and then it's just like I'm always kind
of working and I'm just like every now
and then like I'll see a headline and be
like oh that's [ __ ] up or whatever but
usually I'm like working on something so
I don't usually read news until like
later on or I'll kind of like aggregate
stuff like at the end of the week and
read stuff up so I don't really like
see stuff as it happens necessarily but
man
she's only four years older than me
oh that's that's uh yeah I'm trying to
gonna try and not think about that too
hard holy [ __ ]
that's a bummer
Lisa Marie Presley died yeah I know 54.
yeah
well
was it like sudden or did they know
something probably something drug
related no they said heart uh well
Cardiac Arrest yeah that might be coated
language yeah that's true
I'm gonna show you guys the bikes I got
some videos of the bikes
let me show you the little Honda
John Smith said I took out biking two
years ago just after I turned 40.
coincidence yeah
[Laughter]
Zach says then again King uh Kim Jong-un
had a heart attack at like 30 something
so yeah some people do it's like but
all right
that's the Honda CT yeah it only weighs
50 pounds that's our old house that's in
front of the old house yeah yeah I was
still doing wiring at that time
I was talking about the gas tanks
that's a fun bike to build I built that
in the house
yeah because like you know it's really
small yeah
aluminum wheels dual disc front
you could put up some you can uh hit the
brakes so hard that it will do an endo
I've I've rolled that bike and then
caught it
coming up that
coming up the driveway
I could easily win a competition with
that
just in beauty alone
yeah I mean you did a really nice paint
job on that yeah
that's a wicked little beast he just
brought it back he went to visit his dad
and like his dad gave it to him and it
was kind of it looked okay when he
brought back it was kind of like junky
looking when he brought it back but yeah
he fixed it all up and painted it but
you put new seat on it you put all that
[ __ ] on it yeah you guys don't realize
how
how um
little that is that comes up to my knee
it's very small you can pick it up yeah
yeah it's like a little like a little
mini bike a little munchkin bike yeah
it's not Chrome it's polished aluminum
rims
it only weighs 45 pounds
and I was talking about putting probably
maybe like a GPS Speedo but then when I
just blacked that out because there's no
reason for a speedometer it doesn't go
fast enough to worry about speedometer
it's not like you're gonna [ __ ]
you're not gonna get a ticket yes you're
gonna go 70 that's it
maybe hit 70.
okay Tom sack says the main green sewing
machine yeah uh no it's a four-stroke it
actually sounds real throaty it's like
that it sounds good even though it's
very like I said it's very small yeah
Jeffy art said I believe Lisa Marie's
son died from suicide not that long ago
yeah I remember hearing about that man
that's like that's a [ __ ] bummer
that's my xb12 uh
r with the um
lightning tail on it that bike's kind of
well known in the Buell scene because
there's not many like that one
I got a fiberglass
custom German race tail in there from
Frank's racing
that's what that was the one that I
[ __ ] slid the front end out of it and
got out of it
112 I think 110 horsepower 100 no 104
horsepower at the crank I think so you
end up in the 90s a lot of torque though
I think it's you know 87 or 87 foot
pounds of torque or something there's a
it's a lot of torque
fun bike
and then um
then I got a picture of my xb9
this is back when the nine was silver
it's now black
has a bunch of carbon package on it need
to back off of it so you guys can see it
come on back up I was talking about
something if it is now you know how I am
I [ __ ] run my voice run my mouth run
your mouth no not you yeah hahaha
and then uh
I got a picture of the two I got a video
of the two stroke
also got videos of Jen and the girls
wait what videos are you talking about
when we're doing the photo shoot
remember oh okay when was okay yeah man
you still got that [ __ ] yeah that was a
while back a long time ago all right
it's made a lot of progress since this
time but that's that's the um
that's the two stroke I was working on
yeah you've done more on it oh yeah yeah
that was a long time it was a long time
ago that's even got the old swing arm on
it and the old the old suspension that's
the last video I have on it though
um
there's Jen and the girls at the old
place doing photo shoots look how pretty
they are
oh [ __ ] what am I doing what am I saying
I don't know okay that's the photo shoot
there's Dimitri yeah
there's me and Jenna Laura that's right
that's our friend Brian he's a
photographer yeah look at Jen's boobs
there's the camera
what the [ __ ] there we go
yeah that was fun yeah how long ago was
that about five years probably I don't
remember it was a while ago it was a
while back yeah
it's a while back that ended up on a lot
of posters and stuff yeah we used a lot
of those photos yeah I was using those
for years for like posters I miss your
hair like that Jen remember that
well like I said that was when the front
part of it
she was like I'm I want to be in the
photo shoot too look how funny I am
fishing so cute
that I think this was before we got
Pokey yeah yeah it wasn't a Pookie then
yeah Pookie wasn't born yet yeah Pookie
wasn't born yet
foreign
Beijing does
yeah Zach says patience not like pay me
like one of your French girls yeah yeah
I think like I took a picture of her one
time and I think I captioned it that
because she was totally yeah like yeah
Beijing I'm gorgeous Beijing thinks
she's Paris Hilton she walks around like
she's pretty she's like look at me look
how pretty she's very arrogant she is
and she knows what pretty is yeah so if
the girls got all dressed up she had to
come out there with them all the time
you guys saw it I got it recorded she's
like I'm gonna do a photo shoot too look
how pretty they take a picture she knows
all about it's so much prettier than the
other girls people think that [ __ ]
humans are special over the other
animals nah man [ __ ] other animals
absolutely not they have all they have
they have gender they know what ugly and
they know what pretty is and they know
they know what funny is they they they
do all that [ __ ] they know what we're
doing yeah I mean they they understand a
lot they understand a lot more than you
think they do yeah they absolutely do
yeah
but now Beijing saw the girls dressed up
getting attention and she's like well I
need attention look at how pretty I am
put me in the middle of it
John Smith said cats are especially vain
Yeah well yeah Beijing is for sure
Pookie is not vain
um she's kind of more she's like a
tomboy yeah she likes attention but
she's more like Tom wish she wants to
wrestle yeah basically wrestle wrestle
and eat and uh she wants to be hugged
you hug her and [ __ ] and she likes that
she'll go yeah and brush
it must be brushed oh is she discovered
because I have her she stole one of my
brushes so I was like okay this is yours
now because it's full of like Pooky hair
so that's in my coffee station like kind
of on the other side of it so for a
while she was jumping up getting that
Brushy yeah but today or yesterday
rather she jumped up in my main bathroom
and found my other brush like my wet
hair brush you know what I mean that's a
lot more like the plastic uh you know
spines or whatever
and she jumped up on there and was like
oh this is better yeah and she's like
rubbing on that and she's like now I
want this one so now she's going into
the main bathroom and she's like [ __ ]
that other brush I want this brush so
I'm like okay well I guess we have to
switch the brushes out again because she
wants that one I had to stand there for
like [ __ ] half an hour and brush her
yeah she just like stayed there and kept
yelling every time I wanted to walk away
guys are saying my bikes are sweet yeah
thank you very much yes it's not just
all us doing these [ __ ] shows we got
other [ __ ] we do too
uh which is cool I think
um a lot of people that a lot of uh
YouTubers and people that have shows
that's all they do is the show that
would drive me [ __ ] crazy it's trying
to driving her crazy I gotta get her out
of here well the thing about it is that
um I don't know I think about this a lot
because like I said I kind of feel like
uh you know or the show is cool and
everything like that but I just feel
like I feel I feel like we don't have a
lot of focus but I kind of feel like
that's because I don't have a lot of
focus because there's like a million
things that I like and there's a million
things that I want to incorporate and I
always like every time like a new thing
comes up I'm like ooh that's like a cool
idea let's do that or look that's a cool
you know what I mean it's like anybody
that's like a creative person your mind
is just going like a million miles with
a really good idea but then you realize
logistically what is it going to take to
get that done that's what I mean like oh
[ __ ] because I think yeah I think of
[ __ ] all the time I'm like you know uh
you know I love this idea like but
realistically like how long would it
take me to do it like would it be worth
the effort would it does that so you
really have to kind of like there's not
enough hours in the [ __ ] work week
yeah they're living week to execute some
of the [ __ ] that we come up with yeah
because I come up with [ __ ] like
literally yeah and you're like well [ __ ]
that's a full-time job right to show
would just be that right you know what
time is it
um it's only it's not even seven it's
almost seven yeah we got loads of time
before we have to go I mean it's just
kind of like
I don't know I was thinking that today
because
I don't know I'm just one of those
people it's like I there's a million
things that I like to do and there's a
million things that I'm interested in
and I kind of that's good I don't want
to stop being like that but in some ways
too it's like I don't have
I feel like I don't have a lot of focus
you know what I mean because I don't
like to get just like you know I I love
horror movies and I love True Crime and
stuff like that but I would be really
upset like if the show just had to be
one thing you know what I mean so I kind
of feel like that's why the show is just
so [ __ ] all over the place because
I'm interested in so many things we're
interested in so many things we like so
many things that it's like well we want
to talk about this and we want to talk
about that like if I had to talk about
the same thing all the time I'd probably
go nuts but well you know even more than
I already am but I don't know like in
some ways I think that hurts us because
we're not known for one thing like you
know what I mean like we're not just oh
like known for horror movies or known
for True Crime or known for paranormal
or whatever and so I do feel like
I don't know it's like I said it's been
something that especially like in the
last couple years since we've had
um you know patreon going down and like
ad Revenue going down and stuff like
that I'm just like well maybe we should
just
decide on one and like focus on one
thing but it's like then it's like I
don't know if I want to do that and it's
like even if I could do that what's the
one thing I would focus on because then
I would just be like oh well I want to
do this other [ __ ] you know what I mean
I don't know like today I was thinking
about
like some other project I want to do
as if I don't already have enough
like sometimes well the thing about it
is that
what I've started doing like now that
I'm old and like have a more realistic
outlook on things
I come up with an idea and I'm just like
okay I love this idea today I'm just I'm
gonna write it down I write a paragraph
it's like I had this idea where blah
blah you know what I mean thank you
Jeffy art happy Friday guys Jenny thanks
for the heads up on Martyrs by your
review on scariest lawn I'm telling
everyone I know about your other
channels I know exactly what it's like
being creatively ADHD yeah it's it's a
lot
um but like I said I get really
enthusiastic about things like ooh
that's so awesome it's like I want to
like look into that or I want to look
into doing this and stuff like that but
I realize that's probably not good from
a money making standpoint because like I
said nobody you know I'm not focused on
one thing but
so what I'll do it's like I'll have like
a really cool idea it's like I had an
idea to do this that and the other thing
I'll write it down on a paragraph and
I'll keep it in my like my calendar
thing
and I'm like and I'll just keep
revisiting it because I'll see it every
day because I have a thing where I have
like a little file where I'm just like
what are we doing today I need to do
this video I need to do this that and
the other thing so I just have it at the
bottom of that and then like after a
while like after a few weeks I revisit
them like do I still want to do that is
it worth the effort that it'll take to
do like how much effort realistically
this is gonna take to do it so I don't
know it's like and if I still want to do
it like after a couple months or
something then I'll kind of start
putting it on the schedule and like do
that so what are you doing see if it's
still looking good
oh so I'm so I'm talking and like you
had to take all the attention away okay
because Jenny can't talk about anything
you have to come in and like show your
[ __ ] ABS or whatever
uh Richard Brown said variety is the
spice of life yeah I've just really got
like I said everything that I'm into
it's it's all like dark [ __ ] is you know
what I mean it's always it's always like
crime [ __ ] or you know horror [ __ ] or
art [ __ ] or something like that so it's
not like I'm just all over the place but
jeffy's gave us some money I know okay
okay he said happy Friday guys he said
Jenny thanks for the heads up on Martyrs
via your review on scare Salon I'm
telling everyone I know about your other
channels I know exactly what it's like
being creatively ADHD yeah I'm like I
said in my video If you haven't watched
it yet I put up a video about Martyrs
today it's I have been wanting to do a
video on that movie for a really long
time because this is a movie that I've
been wanting to watch for a really long
time but I was like I don't I don't know
if I'd necessarily say I was scared to
but I was just kind of always like man
everybody talks about how [ __ ] up this
movie is and I really had to be like in
the right headspace to watch it because
it's like I know that this is gonna be
like hard to watch and it's gonna bum me
out and but I still wanted to watch it
you know what I mean
um but I'm glad I watched it but like I
said you know if you're just like a
casually into horror or something like
that don't watch that [ __ ] because
you're not going to be able to get it
out of your brain but I don't know I I
thought it was great I thought it was
like magnificent but
um yeah it's it's uh it's it's a trial
it's excruciating like to watch it
excruciating see I had to fix that that
busted off I got a piece of credit card
back there I grew it in
a piece of an old credit card you know
yeah
Victor says Martyrs literally gave me a
nightmare after I watched it I could see
that I could see that
um
and then John Smith said the US remake
of Martyrs is frankly [ __ ] that's what I
heard like I was thinking about watching
it because I was like well maybe I
should watch it just so I could get a
perspective but literally like every
other review I read like don't even
bother so I was like okay well that's
probably like an hour and a half I'll
never get back so it's like I probably
shouldn't bother so that was just
but yeah I mean it's a [ __ ] up movie
it's not I'm it's not the most [ __ ] up
movie I've ever seen I don't even know
what the most [ __ ] up movie I've ever
seen is
I've seen a lot of [ __ ] up movies
it's but it's pretty [ __ ] up it's
pretty [ __ ] up
um and it's not [ __ ] up like if you
haven't watched the review it's not
[ __ ] up in the way that it's like oh
my God it's so gory or anything like
that it's just
the idea of it is [ __ ] up and like the
violence in it is really realistic and
is [ __ ] up you know what I mean so
John Smith said the US remake has a
happy ending what the [ __ ] no come on
that makes sense I mean what okay
anytime let's talk about this because
anytime like some badass
foreign quote unquote horror movie comes
out and everybody in the horror
Community is a buzz about it all the
American companies are like oh we should
we should do an American remake of that
for American audiences and then they
always completely castrate it
well we need to make it we need to give
it a happy ending and we need to like um
you know lighten up on the gore and the
violence so it's like they do that every
single time I don't think I've ever seen
an American remake
that was you know gory or more violent
or anything like that than the European
or Asian counterpart the only one that
I've ever seen
and one I don't know if this is the only
one but one of the few that I've ever
seen that I thought the American remake
was better than the Asian one and please
don't come at me was the ring
I liked the American the verbinski One
Ring better than uh ring you the
Japanese one which is good but I think
the American one was scarier but that's
the only time I think that's the only
time that I can think of that I've seen
some where the American remake was
almost as good as
but 99.99 of the time the original the
foreign is always better it's always
more [ __ ] up it always gets because
they're not afraid to like go there
they'll make it totally because look at
Martyrs for Christ's sake he's like the
guy that wrote and directed it he said
he's like yeah I was like in a pretty
[ __ ] up place in my life at the time I
was like pretty much suicidal and I was
like yeah it shows in the movie this is
one of the most nihilistic movies I've
ever seen it's super [ __ ] up and I
kind of feel like the American remake
was not gonna do that like because
people can't handle it over here I guess
but the thing about it is that American
horror fans they can handle that kind of
[ __ ] because they're watching the
foreign version I don't really
understand who the American version is
for who is that for I understand it
the people the people that are in these
studios are always trying to make a big
hit so they try to take anything that
was a good and make it more mainstream
we'll get more assets right in the seats
so we would do this we're going to make
it PG and you know and yeah and it's
like why it's like no like horror fans
aren't gonna go see it because it's like
look we already saw the original and
that was like a million times better so
why would we bother with that like
they're gonna get all the 14 year olds
they're just looking at demographics and
numbers and they're going this should
work a lot better and they're full of
[ __ ]
um
that's why really man when it comes to
America American Cinema for the most
part indie films that's really where you
want to be now some of these little
small Studios was that what's that one
a24 yeah that's a smaller Studio they're
Hit or Miss but they're all at least
Originals man they're [ __ ] like I
said I will give them any surprise to
anybody that is like willing to they're
like we're just gonna make some weird
[ __ ] yeah we don't give a [ __ ] he's got
a little bit of heart you know what I
mean some of the big studios it's it's
just schlock and that was really the
standard man people are going well
Hollywood used to be good no it wasn't
Hollywood for the most part wasn't any
good
um well because they're pretty schlock
because they're trying to appeal to the
widest
you know the the broadest swath of
people and whenever you do that it's not
going to be I'm not going to say that
necessarily means it's bad because I've
seen some stuff that was like big
Blockbusters and stuff and they were
good but
I kind of feel like the the more people
you try to appeal to
um the broader spectrum of the people
you try to appeal to like the less
quality It's Gonna Be You See
Hollywood sucked when I was a little kid
but it got revived with some with a
[ __ ] series of a bunch of really good
movies that came out and this and it was
basically Lucas and Spielberg helped
[ __ ] revive Hollywood
and those were Indie guys you know the
the studios really didn't want to deal
with those dudes but they kind of had to
because you're not gonna [ __ ]
you're not going to be doing real well
the 1980s with a bunch of [ __ ] 60s
and 70s [ __ ] cop cop flicks which
that's really what Hollywood made cop
flicks you know and a lot of that was on
the back of bullet bullet was a great
conflict yeah but the thing about it
that was like an indie flick was that
yeah well but 70s conflicts and all
those kind of like political Thrillers
and stuff like that were [ __ ] great
they were great they were great but they
but they were kind of like the exception
of the 70s that wasn't normal for the
70s normal for the 70s was just shocked
[ __ ] now
Nicholas Cage lately he's lately he he's
done some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] because
he'll do anything for money you know how
he is I'm excited about Renfield I just
yeah I'm just gonna say that with some
uh [ __ ] kind of awesome that looks
awesome Khan of Aslan sent me a trailer
for a new
um Western the cage is going to be in
it's a Revenge flick and it's
this old [ __ ] burned out gunfighter
kind of like unforgiving okay and he's
got his daughter with him he's trying to
protect his daughter from some people
that are trying to I guess bring him in
for a bounty
and it looked really good
I don't remember the name of it but I
just saw the trailer today
and well Nicholas Cage is in some
awesome movies
yeah even pig pig is weird that was
awesome it was it was kind of like the
it was a joke it was kind of the
anti-jawick it was so good you think
it's gonna be John Wick it never happens
though okay but it's kind of I was
really into that movie yeah sorry I
thought it was really good well
I would say Mandy well yeah but see that
was weird as [ __ ] too yeah Mandy was
good color out of space I thought was
pretty good I want to see that again
yeah I thought it was pretty good other
people didn't think it worked I thought
it did work it wasn't like I I liked it
but I kind of wish it had been like a
little bit just a little bit better but
other than that like I I don't know I
really fights the animatronic [ __ ]
robots Willy's Wonderland Willie's
Wonderland he didn't say a word in it
that was a badass yeah I like that movie
that was really good
[Music]
um
but no K just when K sometimes
cage is always on all right he's even on
in some shitty flicks that we saw well
because he knows that's what you hire
him yeah yeah that you hire him for
Nicholas Cage the whole package recently
he did like a predator rip-off all right
he was the best part in it but that
movie sucked it lacked soul
um but the the new Western that's coming
out looks really good the Renfield looks
pretty good but looks good too and
Nicholas Holt is in that too like I'm
yeah I'm kind of into that because I
love Nicholas Cage brings it man he
[ __ ] brings it you know as long as
he's on a good project you're gonna have
a good time because he's a good
Entertainer and he can act yeah he's one
of those dudes that like pretty much
anything and I feel like a lot of people
are like this if you heard it's like oh
Nicholas Cage is in it okay we'll go see
that see we'll go see that [ __ ] we'll go
see like it could be like really really
awesome or it just might be like what
yeah my son or might suck but mostly is
pretty good yeah like it's all he's
always worth watching yeah he's always
worth watching now uh there was a couple
other ones that stood out recent years
um
the VFW was it was like a oh I like yeah
it's like a carpenter ripoff that was a
great movie I liked it I liked it I
liked that one uh my friend was my
friend is now for that we wanted to
go to school I didn't know though I
liked it before and he goes oh no I did
sound for that
um yeah that was good like a like it was
kind of like um attack on Precinct 13
yeah but like in a VFW bar like and with
like a new retro win and these are
smaller films man these are smaller
indie films but they got they got soul
always
give like like I said I'm not gonna [ __ ]
on anything like I'll watch anything if
you know it sounds good and you know
everybody says it's good it's like I'll
watch it but I'm kind of always gonna be
like more I'm more of a person that's
like this is my personal Vision yeah you
know what I mean I'm interested to see
that I want to see one part I don't want
to see like a movie that was made by
committee or it's like we're trying to
please everybody or something I don't
really want to see that [ __ ] because
it's usually like really boring I want
to see like one quirky ass person and
they're like this is my weird ass [ __ ]
that I came up with and I'm just like
okay show me yes and it's good I'll
enjoy it yeah some of the um
folk horror was really good man
mid-summer I really liked that one
it was in the same vein as that other
one Jenny likes I don't really I didn't
really like that one as much but I saw
it hereditary hereditary well yeah
that's the same director Arias on the
second viewing of hereditary I liked it
better than I liked it the first
hereditary was so good Midsummer was
good too I think I like mid-summer uh
and that's it and that's legit but I'm
just saying I like hereditary a little
bit better but they were both awesome
Midsummer reminded me so much of the
Wicker man yeah and I was just like man
I could get into this flick this is
[ __ ] awesome well I'm really I like
folk horror yeah there's not enough of
it although I will say if you have
shutter I don't know if it's still on
there but there's a great [ __ ]
documentary on there hopefully it's
still on there because it's a really
good documentary and it's called what
the [ __ ] is it called
um Forest Dark oh [ __ ] it has like a
cool title but it's like three and a
half hours long and it's all about folk
horror and it's really really good I
watched that whole [ __ ] and I kind of
want to watch it again what was the name
of that little chick from [ __ ]
midsummer
Florence uh Florence peel
Florence Pew yeah yeah I like her she's
cute yeah and she did another movie and
she's having a moment these last few
years she's been in a ton of movies yeah
are they good
mostly yeah I kind of feel like she's
been in a lot of stuff wasn't she in
that one that just came out
um called don't worry darling she's I
remember seeing the trailers for that I
like her
she's little
um she's got a cute head she's got this
little big kind of head it's I'm like
Florence fuse has yeah like the shape of
her head it's really cute yeah she was
in another movie that I [ __ ] loved it
was called fighting with my family yeah
where it's kind of that was so fun Paige
the wrestler and it's a good Florida
movie man and they're doing [ __ ] where
places where me and Jen hang out we're
like hey that's right so we passed that
place on the [ __ ] is going on going to
the club all the time you know and it's
just like a really good floor to move
because a lot of it's set in Orlando
yeah a lot of set in Orlando it was
doing the [ __ ] WWE and [ __ ] here and
um and it's about a girl Paige you know
she that was her wrestling name she was
from England and she came here to become
a wrestler and her whole story that's a
it's a movie I really recommend fighting
with my family we saw it in the theater
I think twice a couple times yeah and
then I got it on Blu-ray I liked it so
much better than I I mean I thought I
was gonna like it but it's like when I
saw it I was like it's just it's
delightful it's a delightful movie yeah
yeah it's fun and uh the Blu-ray they
have extended an Extended Cut in it
which is good too the edit is still have
you seen the extended edit yet I thought
we watched it did we not I don't think
you've seen the extended extended it
unless you watched it by yourself one
day yeah I've watched it by myself
there's there's more in it about I think
about 10 minutes more 10 15 minutes more
it's good it's still an enjoyable movie
The Other Florida movie was the [ __ ]
crime movie that [ __ ] yeah
and that was a mainstream flick
okay that's what I mean that's why I
don't really like done real well man
right it was done real well you can't
just say
the big studios suck they just mostly
suck every now and then it they
accidentally a good one gets out and to
be honest too sometimes some indie
movies also suck yeah a lot of Indie
movies you know what I mean so you so
that's what I mean you can't just like
judge if a movie if the premise of a
movie sounds cool then just watch it
like it doesn't matter if it cost like a
hundred million dollars or like 50 000
it's like if it's a good movie it's a
good movie yeah you know one of our
subscribers Louis Hernandez he might
even be he might even be a patron I'm
not sure is he is Louis a patron
um he's basically a patron because he
sends us because he sends us oh [ __ ]
that's the same as being a patron he
sent he sends me movies all the time
and they've all been excellent he's got
excellent taste in movies I know if he
does he's coming from from Louis I'ma
like it uh he sent me collateral [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] good movies
uh one of them was playing a game
he's got I thought Sophie sent us that
no no okay no no
pain again came from Louie yeah okay
yeah he goes oh you'll like this one and
it's an All-Star cast yeah that was like
right in your wheelhouse yeah and then
the same director as Transformers no uh
yeah Transformers or was it Transformer
Pacific Rim what else did he did I
thought Michael Bay did Transformers
yeah it was it was that was a Michael
Bay movie was it it was I'm pretty sure
it was a Michael Bay movie it was it was
his it was a mainstream as [ __ ] but it
was like that was his version of an
indie flick
and it was a True Crime Story see he can
make good movies when he wants to yeah
it's not just two hours of [ __ ]
exploding true crime story about some
dude that was a fitness trainer and on
all these steroids and they [ __ ]
committed this crime with these dudes
from the gym they dress up as a ninjas
to do it and I mean it was based on a
real story actually so and it actually
happened that probably helps and the
rocks in it Dwayne Johnson The Rocks in
it and he's a Bible thumping Christian
bodybuilders it's just it's the rock is
so good in it it's great it's got Mark
Wahlberg he's the [ __ ] main the main
dude who [ __ ] plants the crime and
[ __ ] it's really it's something it's
great and like I said it's based on a
real yeah did we do a show about the
real case behind we need to if we did
because that I thought we thought the
story is Florida as [ __ ] that was the
Genesis of Florida man I kind of feel
like people would watch that movie and
be like man like you can't make that
[ __ ] up but a lot of it was based on
real [ __ ] that's what really happened
um I'm kind of behind with the comments
Jeffy art said uh European and Asian
Cinema tends to take art to more of an
expressive route I agree with Tom
Hollywood treats film is simply a
commodity yeah yeah I kind of feel like
that's why you get a lot of better and
even like it's you know I'm a horror
girl so like in the horror Community
most people are like we want to see like
the foreign movies because they actually
see horror they actually see film as
like an art form and they're not really
worried necessarily about the movie
making or I mean it's nice if it makes a
lot of money sure but that's not like
their primary concern
um you know and I'm not [ __ ] on
people like you know like Blum House for
example because they you know yeah they
make kind of movies for a more
mainstream audience a lot of them are
PG-13 and stuff but I've seen some of
those that were actually pretty good
blumhouse can do good [ __ ] yeah like so
some of those are pretty good but I'm
just so I'm not just saying but like I
said if you want to see something that's
like film as art then yeah that's
probably not the route you want to go
you know Jeffy art said my old bosses
always kept telling us to create to
cater to the masses
no thanks like I know it depends it
can't be done it can be done right
um Spielberg and Lucas when they first
came out
they were catering to the masses but
they did that [ __ ] from the Indie
[ __ ] point of view
think of the [ __ ] that they were doing
[ __ ] Close Encounters of the Third
Kind Jaws
[ __ ]
um
Star Wars
even though that was an indie film but
then uh uh [ __ ] uh [ __ ] Raiders of
the Lost Ark
that was mainstream [ __ ] man yeah um but
it was it just had a [ __ ] classic
into and it holds up to this day it has
a classic feel because it was classic
back then
back then a lot of it she had to
hearkened back to the 1940s is what they
were doing with uh Star Wars in in
Indiana Jones and uh [ __ ] and there
was just something weird magic about
[ __ ] jaws and a weird magic about
Close Encounters
the thing is though is that they tried
to Hollywood tried to go that route for
a long long time
directors have a half-life
you got to keep recruiting new blood
into the system to keep that going
and you did have some new ones [ __ ]
Carpenter okay
kind of came in but for some reason they
wouldn't really
let him fly
and and E.T kicking the [ __ ] out of the
thing it didn't it didn't make any
[ __ ] sense I mean E.T was a great
flick
but they [ __ ] shat on [ __ ] the
thing and I think Carpenter was never
really the same after that you know the
weird thing about this like E.T and the
thing are like two completely different
yeah I mean yeah they're both about
aliens but that's about the only thing
they have in common to be honest they
openly disrespected the thing though
they opened they did they open they were
like no we can't have that that that's
terrible no it wasn't [ __ ] the thing
was [ __ ] an effective movie it was
great still one of my favorites yeah
whole movies of all time right
um oh thank you El padrino what do you
say uh you know gave us a Super Chat
that's awesome like I said I got behind
so sorry uh guys thank you for your
content and your sense of humor I'll do
my best to contribute more in two weeks
let us know when you do Godfather Part
three I don't want to miss that
discussion
um yeah I actually put it if you're um
on our patreon I actually put it in the
poll that's going up tomorrow morning so
if you want to do Godfather 3 go over
there and vote for Godfather Three into
poll and then we'll talk about that on
Sunday yeah like we'll watch we're gonna
watch we're gonna watch it eventually
anyway but yeah move it to the front if
you guys want if you guys vote for it
yeah
because Godfather 2 is the [ __ ]
I think Godfather 2 was actually better
than one yeah and one was awesome yeah
but yeah they did it Richard Brown said
Carpenter was always bigger in England
and France
what the [ __ ] what are you doing
she opened the door
she's going to the cabinet what the [ __ ]
foreign
but yeah that's I kind of feel like yeah
a lot of American filmmakers that didn't
really
get their due in the U.S I kind of feel
like yeah they were bigger in Europe
like that's what Europeans like
appreciated them more than well like I
said it's always there's always been
more of a tradition particularly in
Europe of film as an art form I kind of
feel like they don't I'm not saying they
don't have that in the United States I'm
just saying that it's not
I don't know I just kind of feel like
the American film industry has always
been way more money I think a lot of had
to do with Studios not wanting
competition if they didn't [ __ ] put
their mark on you and you weren't in
their studio and then in their click
then they were gonna [ __ ] on you through
the through the rest of the media that
they also basically owned so they didn't
like Carpenter they didn't want
Carpenter to succeed he did though even
in the face of all that he made some
[ __ ] great B movies that were just
well and people were still talking about
this many years Escape From New York bet
one of the best B movies ever made and
that's not really an action movie but
it kind of made you think it was an
action movie it was just he did a lot of
weird stuff the thing
yeah Dead Zone that's right yeah or no
dead zone was Cronenberg yeah uh yeah uh
they did Christine the yeah Christine
was one of his [ __ ] higher budget
movies from that area that was like a
very mainstream
you you stop it what did she do she
threw that box out of there
you were in trouble now she's going back
to see what that was it's okay Pokey
yeah well what do you expect sit down
down
sit down he's like no I'm not she's
blowing me off right I'm just trying to
sound I don't know what that was
what is that
well there was some kind of little
wrench oh because I have like some tools
and stuff like that yeah actual range a
Wi-Fi Range Extender oh that's the box
from that yeah
uh holy Parish or Doom said Starman is
really good too yeah we you know what
I've been wanting to revisit that we
should probably do a review of that at
some point because I haven't seen it in
a very long time and I kind of feel like
but yeah I always do like to like um you
know kind of give a shout out to
Christine because I feel like a lot of
people forget that John Carpenter
directed that and I think that's one of
his better movies and people don't uh
talk about it all that much you know
what I mean
so let's see
uh where was I
do
already [ __ ] him yeah
why doesn't it say cuntingham I saw
[ __ ] Christine so many times so many
times it was uh when did that come out
83
and it seemed like it was on HBO or
Cinemax or whatever all the [ __ ] time
I saw it so many times and God damn that
it's just so good it's just like a good
adaptation it's I don't it's not a lot
different from the book like they did
change some [ __ ] up but I don't know I
just everything in the like all the cast
everything like that it just worked for
me you know I just I don't know I just
thought it was a really good Stephen
King adaptation and I feel like a lot of
people forget about it
uh El padrino is like talking about
assault from Precinct 13 yeah we yeah we
did a review of that not too long ago
Prince of Darkness I'm ambivalent about
Prince of Darkness like I feel like
it's a really really cool idea
and there's like some really really
creepy scenes in it but I don't think it
was a hundred percent successful which
Prince of Darkness yeah Prince of
Darkness was kind of uh so I'm kind of
like I don't know I'm a little bit on
the fence about that one that one was
what I would call Spumoni you know what
spamoni is yeah it's an Italian ice
cream it's got everything in it it's got
pistachio [ __ ] strawberry
vanilla and [ __ ] chocolate and nuts
and [ __ ] mirrors you know Cherry it's
just too [ __ ] much and none of that
[ __ ] went together
that's what [ __ ] that's what that
movie was like
you didn't notice that yeah none of that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] coherent
he was just trying that's what I mean
well I kind of feel like it was a good
idea yeah I liked the concept of it but
it didn't really cohere no it didn't
joke it didn't cohere it didn't jump but
it's still a good movie it's still worth
watching I don't think I don't think
spamoni's any good either I don't know
if I've ever had it I know what it is
but I don't think I've ever had it's
their version of Neapolitan the Italian
version of Neapolitan ice cream is too
[ __ ] much
too much [ __ ] [ __ ] although you could
say I guess you could say that a [ __ ]
a banana a banana split is kind of like
that but
well I wouldn't eat that because [ __ ]
bananas yeah yeah I don't like bananas
[ __ ] the bananas uh El padrino said it
was near dark a good movie I don't
remember it yes near dark was a was an
awesome movie that was like the vampire
one with like uh sounds familiar yeah
yeah we did a review of it not too long
ago yeah
remember with uh Bill Paxton in it
the Vampire movie and they were kind of
like the they were the group and they
were like in the world yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that yeah that was pretty
good yeah that was uh that was that's on
shutter at the moment it was hard to get
hold of yeah so that's that's Carpenter
too wasn't it no that's uh Catherine
Bigelow oh okay I think they were
running around in the damn van with the
windows closed yeah and then the kid the
vampire and they yeah they have a whole
vampire in the [ __ ] Honky Tonk bar
scene out the [ __ ] Southwest
that was a good movie that had uh the
dude from Lance what's his name Lance
henriks Henderson was in it yeah that
was actually a good movie you'd like
that yeah yeah I liked it a lot yeah
thank you very much Stuart Patterson
gave us a Super Chat uh missed this last
year nearly killed me uh recluse to
myself from everything never mind got
plenty Stella yeah that's good Estella
yeah you guys and a bunch of names I
remember love you all ah thank you we
remember you we remember you we're glad
you returned yeah mango said near dark
is amazing
it is
um I enjoyed it ear dark is really good
thing is I only saw like the first time
I saw near dark was with Jenny just like
because I told you I was like yeah yeah
because we did a review of it like not
too long ago so I didn't grow up with
that one I must have been in the Army
when that came out what year was that uh
when did nerdar come out a late 80s or
early 90s okay I could have been I could
have been in the army
we're getting ready to go in the army I
didn't but I would have liked it I just
didn't see it I also didn't I didn't see
The Hitcher or The Hitchhiker what's The
Hitcher The Hitcher I didn't see the
history 86 I didn't say it until much
later yeah cause we did a review of that
too because I was like oh my God you got
to see The Hitcher the edger is so
[ __ ] good pretty good I wish I would
have saw it back then had I seen it back
then yeah made a bigger impression made
you get to see Jennifer Jason Leigh
pulled apart like um pulled in half by
two trucks yeah so you know
[Laughter]
it was [ __ ] awesome through it
you know yeah what's his name
this Blade Runner uh
[ __ ] now now you made me forget you
forget yeah now you made me forget yeah
foreign guy
I almost couldn't pay Roy what was that
Disney you guys know who we're talking
about I always said Dolph Lundgren no
that's a totally different dude wrecker
Howard Rucker Howard
thank you
getting old sucks yes
[Laughter]
oh my God record was cool man but he he
let himself go he started to gain a
bunch of weight and [ __ ] I guess he was
just sit around drinking beer or
something and
they didn't he's probably like yeah [ __ ]
it they didn't know about [ __ ] they
didn't know about HRT back then only
only certain dudes knew
but uh it was that [ __ ] was Ultra
experimental so a lot of those guys aged
out faster than they really should have
um
which is sad because [ __ ]
some of those guys disappeared when
there was a lot left there was a lot of
mileage in them had they been you know
what I mean our generation
people are not aging is
quickly as they used to
manga says better than uh Lost Boys
which came out the same year in 1987.
yeah that's right like I look I like I
love the lost boys that's just the
soundtrack man alone [ __ ] those place
is good yeah I mean that Echo and the
bunny man cover if people are strangers
like it's pretty iconic
but you know I mean I put them right
there with each other they're yeah yeah
I mean there's times yeah they're both
vampire movies but they're kind of
coming at it from like a slightly
different angle so that's okay the
Richard Brown said have you seen the
Sean Bean Hitcher I have not um I've
heard that it was like pretty good and I
do like Sean Bean so I mean I'll
probably watch it at some point somebody
sent me a crystal flip
I don't remember if that was Rob
Levinson
it was the one where it was like one of
the one of Crystal's best movies where
his
his wife gets abducted by some dudes
that are getting that breakdown
breakdown
weren't they cannibals
wait or were they just murdering people
I thought I gotta see it again I thought
they were easy well I don't know if
you're confusing it with Hills Have Eyes
though
because it's been a while it wasn't that
I know that they were I know that they
were abducting people
I thought they might have been eating
them too but it's been a long time since
I've seen it I got to see that one again
that was a breakdown breakdown was a
good play I liked it and that was
[ __ ] Crystal [ __ ] across a planet
every man trying to [ __ ] save his
family
I got to see it again though I have it
I haven't yeah we did a review of it not
a like yeah well it was probably like a
couple years ago because I think we were
still at the old house I liked it it was
like a um it was a movie from its time
but it would like would it would have
been awesome to see it in those days I
didn't see it in those days well it was
kind of like it was in the same
sub-genre as like The Hitcher or
um like duel yeah like or something like
that or uh what's that other what's that
one from Australia Road games yeah like
it was kind of like that yeah you know
what I mean yeah I gotta see that one
again yeah
I forgot who said it to me somebody said
somebody said mango said if I recall
right it was slave trading and breakdown
yeah see that's what I thought I didn't
think they were cannibals I thought like
no they were thinking of like Hills Have
Eyes maybe yeah maybe it was maybe sex
slaves or something maybe yeah that's
not about right yeah
I gotta see it again
and they were a bunch of normal farmer
looking people
it had trucks we'll see there are others
we're doing it like you know I don't
know why people expect serial killers
and stuff like that to look like
Monsters or something they just
like Wednesday said in the original
Adams Family movie She's a serial killer
they look like everyone else that's how
they get away with it
um yeah Road games is from Australia
yeah I think we reviewed that one as
well even though there wasn't Jamie Lee
Curtis in that I kind of want to feel
like Curtis was in that but it was a
similar kind of thing where it's like
you know somebody's stalking you on the
highway type situation so there's like a
whole sub-genre of movies like that
Al padrino said please do a video review
of vice squad with wings Hauser that is
some funny [ __ ] okay I don't know that
one let me write that down I don't think
I've ever seen that thank you gadget3
hey hey can post has Gadget now apple is
weird Okay well thank you very much I'm
gonna write what did I say bye Squad
okay
I'm trying to write stuff down all right
you talk for a second because I'm gonna
run commercials I'm gonna go to the
bathroom we gotta run commercials you
gotta run commercials run the
commercials you're not going to talk we
got to do commercials people if we don't
we'll never do the commercials
and then it'll be too late because then
I was too late to run the Run
commercials plug we're gonna pull we
gotta you're gonna say run commercials
[ __ ]
I want commercials [ __ ]
all right so we'll be back in just a
second I'm gonna run to the bathroom so
we're gonna play some commercials here
here we go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
now was acknowledged the presence of the
Red Death
[Music]
is
flames
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ly
Jenny makes all this [ __ ] beautiful
commercials and writes all these [ __ ]
great books and she never plugs them
well she never plugs them they want to
make sure it's hard to plug your own
stuff I'm just going we gotta plug I'm
always just kind of like here with this
thing
she just tries to [ __ ] survive
it's probably pretty good just off of
Amazon reviews
plug it no I'm PR I'm proud of her her
material she writes good [ __ ] she makes
really great graphic designs of
commercials and [ __ ] [ __ ] it's you
know your intros and your outros are
great you know just but see we never
talk about the [ __ ] on the shows though
well the top of it is some of it we talk
about the [ __ ] of it is that usually 95
of the time I feel like people that are
creative that like really like to make
things don't like they're not supposed
to sell things it's just those two it's
very very rare that you find somebody
that's good at both of those things and
I am absolutely not good at selling
anything we go to horror conventions
[ __ ] we'll bring a [ __ ] bunch of
books with us I'll sell every one of
those [ __ ]
I'll sell I'll sell out on them
see if it was like up to me I would just
sit there because I'm just like it's
hard to sell yourself yeah it's so much
easier to sell and well because it's
because I'm not a real
um
I don't know I'm just I'm not a real
outgoing person I'm not a real like hey
look at what I did kind of person like I
I don't know I just feel like a fraud or
like a douche like doing that so you
know what I mean
so it's always easier to have somebody
else do it for you yeah
I go out there and just be like hey I'm
off
it's like I don't really
I don't know I don't really think that
well because the thing too and what I'm
getting back to is that a lot of people
that are like creative people
we're like the most critical about our
own [ __ ] so it's like you know I write a
story and I'm just like God that's the
worst [ __ ] [ __ ] ever like why like
other people will read it and they'll be
like oh that's awesome I'm just like no
it's not what the [ __ ] are you talking
about why you like just doing nice to me
is it the same way you do right and
that's what I'm saying it's just like if
that's what I'm saying that's why I
usually created people are not good at
selling their own stuff because it's
just like
when you're acting on stage
you might [ __ ] because I've done this
before I was a trained actor and uh did
something Trenton that did some in
Brazil
used to love [ __ ] singing musicals
and uh I was a kid then you know back
when I was pretty anyway [ __ ] back
when you looked like Rick Springfield
look like with a bullet and [ __ ]
when you had Jesse's Girl when I had
just
after the show I'd be like man I [ __ ]
I
I'm bad about it I was like man that was
not a [ __ ] really good performance
really you know
it was like but then I'd have [ __ ]
people that were from the audience yeah
man that was a great show man you did a
great job you know but [ __ ] and I was
a kid basically ahead of adults that
wanted to meet me and stuff you know
especially later on [ __ ] uh when I
was doing leads like you know
to do more lead roles like it was the
lead Elgato and Fantastics and did some
other leads did some commercials and
[ __ ]
kind of glad I didn't go down that path
though [ __ ] I didn't want to be an
actor really I liked it but I wanted to
be something real you know join the
military and
[ __ ] having fun and
in that realm was a lot more of my speed
and then we didn't have YouTube back
then now that we have YouTube I could
have a mixture of everything
yeah and I appreciate this in a
different way than Jen does because for
me this is just more like a stage
performance a live performance
and it's fun because we we don't really
we're we're the masters of our own
[ __ ] ship you know
but what Jenny's talking about is that
when she writes these books she gets
that kind of feeling that I had when
that sometimes I would do some shows I
have that about every single right where
you're never good enough you're critical
about your own work yeah you know
because it wasn't what I wanted right
and and another thing is that you're
seeing it from behind the stage when you
make it yeah you're seeing it from
behind the scenes so you kind of know
where the problems used to be that you
fixed and you and you see the seams and
[ __ ] in the world well this is where
I kind of mixed two ideas to get but the
person that's in front of the stage
watching it doesn't know any of that
know all that so they don't experience
all that the same way like
intellectually I know that right but
it's like really really hard for me to
internalize that you're because you knew
the creative process you knew what it
was like to build it
and and so you like I said you know you
know what the components are so you're
more critical of it you're seeing it
like a machine and it never comes out
the way you want it right yeah and it's
like really frustrating right but the
audience doesn't see that they saw it as
a smooth
seamless product
they don't know where it came from it
was just an experience that they had
which that means you did your job that's
true that's you did your job yeah
Richard Brown said your stories are so
good Jenny well thank you
I mean I had a good time writing them
I've I've written a couple novels as
well but honestly like short stories are
kind of my more preferred medium
particularly with horror I kind of feel
like stuff that's shorter is like more
impactful at least like to me like I
like reading short stories I like novels
too I'm not saying that but I like short
stories for horror like it's better to
sustain like the um the scare Factor
like over like a short period of time
Jen and I met in a club under social
circumstances I was not a fan of Jan you
know I mean I don't know her writings
and it I've read some of them but it was
much later uh so it's not like we hooked
up like you know like oh man you know
she's a famous writer and it didn't go
that way
but everybody I know that has [ __ ]
read her stories they don't quite look
at her the same way as they used to her
because her shit's hardcore man she's
[ __ ] graphic
the graphic horror
um cannibalism weird [ __ ] man [ __ ]
it's just weird [ __ ] she's weird and I
haven't read everything thank you
I'll take that as a comment yeah a
friend of ours read her stuff because
man it's hard to believe that that's
coming from you okay but yeah my mom
said that to me yeah yeah yeah
then he later on it's like man I thought
a man wrote that that's what he [ __ ]
said that's what he said he says if I
didn't know that I didn't know a woman
rewriting like like that but [ __ ]
that's just to be honest some of the
most [ __ ] up horror that I've read was
written by a woman yeah
yeah we have all kind of ideas
me kind of was like a mixture of [ __ ]
king and the dude that [ __ ] uh what
was that guy who wrote all that weird
sexual stuff hey Clyde Barker Clyde
Barker well I kind of feel like Clive
Bar ger
was frog those two guys you'd like where
she writes I kind of feel like he was my
biggest I love Stephen King I started
reading Stephen King when I was young
like honestly when I was a kid
I I was a horror nerd from like birth as
soon as I was old enough to read as soon
as I was like two or three years old all
I wanted was like ghost stories and [ __ ]
about witches and stuff like that I just
loved that [ __ ] from when I was a little
kid
so I read Edgar Allan Poe I read HP
Lovecraft I read all that stuff when I
was little and then when I got a little
bit older like you know 9 10 11 like I
started reading Stephen King and then it
was when I was 11 or 12 years old I read
the books of blood Clyde Barker
that was what made me want to be a
horror writer I said I want to do what
this [ __ ] I read one of his
books man I [ __ ] liked it but I don't
remember the name of it it was about a
guy you might know who it was about a
dude who gets locked up and goes to
prison
loses his wife while he's in there and
then when he gets out he tries to re
tries to get a new job and he works for
this billionaires like a a groundskeeper
he's a real rich guy and it turns out
that this rich guy was having these
weird orgies and [ __ ]
and then it he was he started the rich
guy tried to get him involved in these
weird orgies
and then it turned out it was
rich people
having orgies
with spirits and demons
and then the spirits of animals also
were in there was like a big bestiality
thing that was going on and I forgot
what it was they were trying to do I was
gonna try to bring in some kind of like
a an antichrist or a messiah and get
some woman pregnant by these demons get
the the animals and demons was that the
damnation game it might have been the
name of it I remember the name oh what
John Smith just said the damnation
damnation that was the first thing I
read that but a long long time ago yeah
I liked that she writes [ __ ] like that
sometimes yeah I kind of write I don't
know I don't I don't even know what I
would call the style to be honest I
don't know I just kind of like Get ideas
and just do what whatever you know what
I mean
damnation game it's been a long time
since I've read that I have it in here
somewhere like the paperback of it I
read that like in uh 2000 um
four maybe
I don't know when it came out but I
think I read in 2004
yeah it's been out a long time okay it
was a good book I mean all his [ __ ] is
good I don't I haven't read everything
but I've read like most of his stuff I
think one of my favorite ones I really
like the books of blood because like I
said I like his short stories
um in the Hills the cities is one of my
favorite short stories of all time and I
wish somebody would make a movie out of
that [ __ ]
um I think my favorite novel of his was
maybe
weave World which is interesting because
it's usually that's kind of more fantasy
and I don't usually go in that direction
but it's like I don't know I just really
really liked the concept of that one
cold heart Canyon was actually really
good too you know what I mean yeah holy
person is Eyes Wide Shut meets yeah yeah
exactly it's like yeah Eyes Wide Shut
damnation came out I think it came out
of this I kind of feel like it came out
in the 80s 80s okay
um and the thing is about it like I
really like
um old school like Gothic ambiguous
horror like I like old school like 19th
century ghost stories I'm really into
that kind of stuff like I like Wilkie
Collins I like Algernon Blackwood I like
all that kind of stuff but I also really
like
kind of extreme horror too I like Clive
Barker I like [ __ ] like Edward Lee or
like Douglas Clegg or like remember like
back in the 90s when there was just this
whole kind of like where that everybody
was just kind of like pushing the
envelope and they were trying to make
everything as like [ __ ] disgusting
and graphic as possible like I like that
kind of stuff too but I kind of like a
mixture of those two things so it
depends on like what kind of mood I'm in
I guess but
you know I I like a vast variety of
of things I don't know if I yeah I have
like particular favorites in horror
books or horror movies or whatever
there's going to be some things that I
like more than others I don't usually
like
um I'm not usually into like more
fantasy stuff I'm not usually into
sci-fi stuff I'm not usually into
um zombies or post-apocalypse or
anything like that but that doesn't
necessarily mean that I wouldn't like
something that was in that vein like if
it was really well done usually I'm into
like more Gothic horror or more like
extreme horror gory horror like
psychological real [ __ ] up kind of
stuff I like that kind of stuff but I'll
read pretty much anything or I'll watch
pretty much anything you know what I
mean like to just depending on what it
is if it sounds like interesting but you
know there's there's some things that
I'm kind of over
but that doesn't mean that I'm not going
to watch something that is about that
because I'll pretty much watch anything
um
Zach says I like my horror more cerebral
and existential I do too largely largely
but then I mean like I said but it
depends on my mood like I'm I'm just
kind of like today I'm just kind of like
man I just want to watch
you know a bunch of zombies like you
know eat people's intestines today and
like not think too hard about it and
it's like I'll enjoy that just as much
but generally like most of my favorite
horror movies I feel like are usually
psychological horror or like haunted
house type stuff or more ambiguous type
stuff that's usually my favorite kind of
stuff
okay you want the rest of this yeah
because I can't drink anymore of this I
have to drive that's right but you still
got a while I mean it's not even it's
not even eight o'clock in yeah it's
almost time to where you start getting
ready in a while yeah
um let's see Richard Brown says uh Mr
James Arthur Mackin yeah yeah like I
like all that kind of stuff like all
that really weird creepy
I like all that kind of like Gothic
horror like you know night all that 19th
century [ __ ] like early 20th century
[ __ ] I love that kind of style she was
writing horror fiction but it turned out
that in terms of sales on Amazon
non-fiction and crime sold better so
that was the way she started to go and
uh the pair the uh
paranormal not a paranormal [ __ ]
non-fiction I guess you know Poltergeist
case that sold pretty good too
so she just kind of went to where the
market was but she had been wanting to
get back into fiction too yeah she likes
doing that
well yeah it's more fun for me like I'm
I like writing True Crime you know it's
I know that's a weird thing to say but I
do like writing about murders yeah
um but yeah I have kind of missed
writing just horror stories where I
could just make stuff up and I kind of
really would like to get back to doing
that
but I don't know we'll see because it's
you know I I see other people's stuff
like it's like I read other people's
horror like I watch horror movies all
the time like to review them and stuff
like that and I'm just kind of like man
I really miss doing my own [ __ ] you know
what I mean because I used to really
like to come up with [ __ ] ideas like
that I mean it's stressful for me
obviously because that's just how I do
but yeah between the show and everything
though you know there's a time that's
the problem yeah that's what I mean
because it's like yeah I can't really
justify it's like oh well I can't take
like an entire day or entire three weeks
or something like that like to just like
kick out some horror stories as much as
I'd want to but it did take her six
months to write a fiction book probably
I don't know about that I could probably
write one of those well like I said I
did kind of like I've written like bits
and pieces of one that I probably have
you know maybe like a quarter of it hmm
like just at random times like because I
had an idea and I was like oh I should
write this down before I forget about it
so it I have it all
like outlined and I started writing it
and so I don't know if it's quite 25 but
it's pretty close so I have like a
quarter of it done and I was gonna do I
was gonna do it like a whole because you
know I'm a graphic designer too and I
really like
um I really like the idea you know like
kind of what um uh like Grady Hendricks
does where he does like what he did with
horror story where he wrote like a
horror story but he made it
look like a um like an Ikea catalog
because the story was about like a
haunted Ikea type store and so he made
it look like that and like Incorporated
that into the story so I really like
that form meeting function type [ __ ] I
really like book as art object you know
what I mean so I really like the idea of
like a story and the design of it like
going it's you know like obviously the
most obvious example being like House of
leaves you know what I mean so I really
like stuff like that where it's all just
kind of like one thing and so what I was
thinking about doing with the story that
I've been thinking about for the last
year or two
was that I want it to look like it's
going to be like a nested story like
modern day but then like [ __ ] that
happened back in the 1930s but I want it
to look like I don't want to say found
footage necessarily but I want it to
look like that like it's kind of like
files of like somebody that was working
on a case so I want it to look like that
so when you buy the book
you know it looks like you're delving
into somebody's
files of like all this stuff that they
found you know what I mean I like that
kind of [ __ ] I like that more in book
form than movie form you know what I
mean like the found footage Trope I like
that more in book form Richard said he's
Richard Brown says he's gonna be getting
the novels too
well I hope you like those as well like
I said novels I I feel like my novels
came out good but like I said short
stories is more of my preferred
when I write fiction I kind of like
doing short stories more
but I think my novels came out okay
they're not like super super long I
don't really understand because you know
how some of those people can
like they just come up with like an
entire [ __ ] universe and they'll
write like [ __ ] 10 books in that [ __ ]
like with a whole interconnected and I'm
just like
I don't understand how people have the
brains to like do that
like I'm not organized enough to do that
that I think that's why I like short
stories better because it's like I just
write one story and it's like you know
20 30 40 pages long and it's just like
that's just the end of it you know what
I mean that I can move on to something
else I don't have to like keep track of
all the [ __ ] details in my head which
is too much okay the show's been going
on for two hours now okay
um do you want something to eat before
we leave we probably should have
something okay before we leave I got
some chicken thawed down there I'll make
this chicken sandwich or something like
that how does that sound yeah okay
sounds good well like I said we don't
have to leave for like another hour or
so yeah you gotta get ready yeah but
literally all I have to do is change
clothes okay but I have to cook and put
shoes I have to cook and I do stuff so
an hour that's about right well hour
hour and a half it's about right like
you know what I mean if we don't leave
till 9 30 that's not that big an alien
okay and then I gotta go get gas on the
way back so no this is about time to
shut it down all right all right so
hopefully you guys uh enjoyed hanging
out with us this Friday evening uh have
a good rest of your night have a good
day tomorrow we'll see you guys again on
Sunday like I said if you're on our
patreon you can go in there and vote uh
for what movie you want us to talk about
on Sunday Godfather 3 is on there so if
you want to talk about that like go in
there and like vote for that uh there's
a I don't remember what else I put in
there
but you can vote on that too so uh so
yeah thank you everybody for super chats
thanks for hanging out with us we will
see you guys again on Sunday evening
good night
[Music]